notre séquence présidentielle comme tous
les jours dans cette émission un débat
complet consacré à l'élection et à
18 jours du premier tour alors on vous
propose de revivre les moments forts de
ces derniers mois avec un regard décalé
celui de 4 correspondant étranger ils
ont choisit des dates clés dans cette
campagne on va les entendre dans un
instant mais d'abord samia de shirky
analyse l'une des particularités notre
paysage politique des partis politiques
historiques à la peine et néo populisme
ou plus au
sondage après sondage la montée de
l'extrême droite se confirme a eu 2
marine le pen et eric zemmour totalise
plus du tiers des intentions de vote un
phénomène qui touche toutes les grandes
démocraties
l'afd en allemagne la ligue en italie et
plus récemment le parti vox en espagne
qui vient d'entrer pour la première fois
dans un gouvernement régional la france
a été de ce point de vue là un peu
innovante elle a été un peu en avance
avec le front national de jean-marie le
pen
dès les années 80 et ses premiers succès
en 84 aux européennes notamment et
ensuite on a bien vu que ce phénomène
s'est diluée je dirais à travers
l'europe et on l'a vu également à
travers le monde c'est la nouveauté des
c'est extrêmement rare et c'est
nationalisme c'est que ces nationalisme
sont devenus internationaux et notamment
grâce aux réseaux sociaux grâce à
internet qui leur permet d'échanger des
idées à travers la planète si la france
ne fait pas exception dans cette poussée
de l'extrême droite l'effondrement des
partis traditionnels semblent en
revanche être une spécificité française
alors que les sociaux démocrates sont au
pouvoir en allemagne en espagne et au
portugal
le parti socialiste français lui connaît
une longue descente aux enfers et si
valérie pécresse est éliminée au premier
tour de la présidentielle la droite
républicaine pourrait connaître le même
sort les partis politiques en france
n'ont pas su se positionner nous sommes
dans un régime qui ne plus en plus
présidentiel présidentialiste on ne
parle plus que des candidats on parle
très peu des projets alors que lorsque
vous regardez les autres démocraties
européennes
on est dans un gouvernement de coalition
il faut faire des compromis et donc tout
ne vient pas d'un seul homme ou d'une
seule femme au pouvoir c'est la 5ème
république à mon avis qui est en crise
et qui peut expliquer que faute de
contre-pouvoir au parlement eh bien les
électeurs se tourneraient maintenant
plutôt vers des partis radicaux est
extrêmement ce qui explique aussi une
autre part q la ridt et française la
percée de la gauche radicale en
parallèle de celle de l'extrême droite
derrière emmanuel macron et marine le
pen jean-luc mélenchon est désormais en
troisième position dans les sondages
la présidentielle avec le regard de
quatre correspondants de médias
étrangers à paris alain navarro pedro
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
correspondante pour plusieurs médias
portugais paolo levi bonsoir
correspondant en france pour la nhtsa et
la stampa richard wehrli bonsoir bonsoir
correspondant permanent du quotidien
suisse le temps à paris et vous publiez
aujourd'hui la france contre elle-même
aux éditions grasset avec nous également
en duplex en visioconférence à l'hameçon
edge qui est correspondant du times à
paris bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi et
évidemment laëticia cuba est resté à mes
côtés merci à tous d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et vous êtes prêté au jeu
puisque je vais demander de choisir des
des moments forts de la campagne mais
avant de les découvrir alain azerot
pedro votre première action c'est autour
de cette décision de nos confrères de
tf1 de diffuser le film les visiteurs à
21h30 le 10 avril au soir du premier
tour j'étais bof mais quand j'ai appris
ça geruge aider c'est pas une blague
c'est pas un fake news puis après je oui
non si on considère bientôt tout bien
réfléchi cette campagne n'intéresse pas
tellement les français
tf1 a dû en prendre acte se dire y'a pas
assez de temps de cerveau disponible
pour la phrase de patrick le lay à l'est
pas pour la pub et donc on va passer sur
quelque chose de plus bankable que les
élections que l'élection le choix par
les français de premier personnage de
l'état
c'est assez extraordinaire de voir cela
parce que c'est quand même une télé
privée c'est une télé donc qui doit
faire de l'argent et qui va le faire en
mettant de côté l'un des moments les
plus importants de ce pays comment on
sait que les français ne sont pas
intéressés par cette campagne c'est très
prétentieux la part de tf1 finalement de
précéder comment ça style c'est ce que
disent les sondages
les sondages le 19 ans est une unité de
mesure peut-être pour tf1 mais
nous-mêmes qui sombre contact des
français tous les jours non jeûnés
étrangers peut-être plus que certains
français même mais non mais voit
bien que 150 personnes au maximum
peut-être 200 parce que vous avez un
réseau très grand mais 270 réseau c'est
de nous poser avec les gens alors toulon
20 et ils disent vraiment ils sont pas
intéressés mais il explique pourquoi
aussi parce que pour certains ils disent
et s'intéresse pas à nos problèmes à
nous mais ça ne m'intéresse pas non plus
et puis en plus soyons clairs il n'y a
pas de suspense d'après des sondages
encore à l'issue moi je passe mon temps
émissions avant l'émission et dire qu'il
ya encore beaucoup d'indécis il y a
30% encore des français qui ne se sont
pas décidés même si effectivement
il ya à priori si on peut les voir les
chiffres puis sûr vous allez me suivre
en régie tout de suite on l'avait prévu
plus tard mais c'est cet intéressant sur
le risque d'abstention c'est un sondage
bva pour rtl orange au début de cette
semaine 21 mars 71 71 % des français
alors on n'est pas sur le on n'est pas
sur le bon on n'est pas sur les bons
mais vous allez suivre 71% des français
voilà ont l'intention de voter à la
présidentielle
on serait au niveau du premier tour de
2002 avec cette participation l'a71
c'était 71 600 en 2002 mais bien au delà
bien en dessous d'autres scrutins
présidentiels paoli lévy est ce que il
reste trois semaines pour mobiliser les
électeurs mais est-ce que vous avez ce
même sentiment et je voulais un instant
que cette campagne est le n intéresse
pas beaucoup les français et du coup un
peu moins aussi vos lecteurs
non en italie bah écoute et non j'ose
espérer jusqu'au bout que c'est pas le
cas ça m'étonnerait que les français ne
s'intéressent pas à leur élection
d'autant plus que c'est une élection qui
suscite un intérêt dans les autres pays
européens parce que le choix d'un
président français aujourd'hui au sein
de l'europe peuvent avoir un impact
direct sur la vie des citoyens italiens
espagnols allemands donc c'est très
embêtant c'est vraiment perçu comme ça
absolument disons que nos pays sont de
plus en plus entre l'as et
interdépendants interdépendants un de
l'autre je considère aujourd'hui qu'une
élection présidentielle française passée
- peut-être une phrase un peu forte mais
c'est presque une question de politique
intérieure pour des iden y est c'est
très important vous avez vu ces
dernières deux années qu'est ce qu'on a
pu faire ensemble pour sortir de la
crise due à la pandémie je pense
notamment aux plans de relance qui a été
rendue possible c'est vraiment une
petite révolution copernicienne qui a
été fait parce qu'elle introduit pour la
première fois en europe une forme de
mutualisation de la dette et donc de
fraternité européenne et cela a été
possible grâce justement à l'union de
grands pays européens comme l'italie et
la france qui ont fait pour la première
fois tombée ce qui était un tabou
allemand quelque part mais qui est l
europe de la rigueur de l'austérité riz
qu'on connaît très bien donc vraiment je
souhaiterais voir
le plus grand nombre d'électeurs
français aller aux urnes le 10 et le 24
mai parce que c'est un moment très
important aussi pour l'histoire mondiale
où on est où on voit les vend des hot
harkis d'aider d'autres modèles qu'ils
cherchent de s'imposer mais on regarde
toujours ce que les populistes fonds
d'en être
et on se livre à ici utilisée pour la
démocratie il serait aussi un excellent
c'est inné de la chimie richard wehrli
dans votre livre vous décrivez une
france en guerre contre elle même et
est-ce que vous retrouvez ce constat
finalement dans cette campagne
présidentielle oui parce que la france a
un talent au lait français peut-être
mais le pays aussi l'un un talent
particulier pour se dresser des
obstacles qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
surmonter au fond le thème du livre j'ai
suivi une ligne de fracture terrible qui
était la ligne de démarcation et 1940 à
ce moment là sans doute peut-être le
seul moment de l'histoire contemporaine
où la france a été vraiment menacée de
disparition elle pouvait disparaître
l'histoire a montré qu'elle n'a pas du
tout disparu y compris même pendant la
guerre mais depuis lors on met sans
arrêt les fractures et ce qui se passe
avec la campagne est assez je dirais
révélateur c'est à dire que beaucoup de
gens sont en train de dire cette
campagne ne fonctionne pas il n'y a pas
de choix il n'y a pas de débat autrement
dit on mais l'obstacle avant même
d'entamer le débat moi je pense que 1 là
l'intérêt l'intérêt des électeurs pour
la pour la campagne pour l'enjeu il est
là il est présent mais les gens ont
aussi conscience des circonstances très
particulières et au delà des
circonstances c'est à dire de la guerre
en ukraine il ya quand même une vraie
question posée c est ce que dans le
contexte de cette guerre on peut demain
gouverner la france autrement et ça
c'est au fond le vrai sujet et c'est à
dire compte tenu du fait que il y aura
une énergie très cher j'ai pas besoin de
vous énumérer on va me faire virer en
balance est ce que demain il y à une
alternative est au fond la force
aujourd'hui d'emmanuel macron c'est
celle là c'est que il y a un côté
incontournable à la manière de diriger
la france demain et donc le fait que les
français peut-être n'aille pas aux yeux
ne signifie pas qu'ils sont pas
intéressés par la politique je suis pas
sûr que l'abstention de 2022 aura la
même signification que l'abstention de
2002 et puis elle n'est pas écrite
encore une fois il ya trois semaines il
peut se passer beaucoup de choses à
l'homme said la la presse britannique et
l'opinion britannique est ce qu'elle
reste tourné un petit peu vers la france
malgré le bric site
pour les élections précédentes à cause
évidemment les domaines actuelle était
international à
aussi peut-être parce que les sondages
montrent à deuxième tour
macron le pen même pas dernière fois
c'est toujours moins intéressant quand
vous avez les mêmes têtes que la
dernière fois à une victoire du
président une place donc pour tous et
toutes ces raisons
il y a moins d'intérêt que d'habitude en
cette élection présidentielle française
je suis passé au que le président soit
un facteur on s'intéresse toujours à la
force on n'était pas content
à la france comme je pense pas que ça
soit fond de montagne mais par la force
des choses cette élection de nous et
a fait moins d'impact médiatique que les
élections précédentes oui c'est sûr on
va parler d' emmanuel macron un petit
peu d'abord avec vous laeticia sont son
parti à l'om qui a finalement pas
vraiment profité de de ce quinquennat
pour renforcer ou en tout cas pas
suffisamment puissamment son maillage
territorial alors ça c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire là c'est même un
euphémisme d'ailleurs c'est presque un
parti fantoche quoi mais on se rend
compte que finalement avec parti de rien
finalement il a été créé à partir de
rien aucune assise aucun ancrage il a
réussi à gouverner emmanuel macron avec
une assemblée nationale majoritaire et
donc il propose un nouveau modèle pour
nous c'est tout à fait inédit ce paysage
politique là il me semble qu'il ya une
erreur dans
l'appréciation que l'on fait de
l'arrivée d'emmanuel mâcon dans la
politique française et de son
quinquennat parce que souvent on entend
qu'emmanuel macro est responsable de la
disparition des partis politiques oui
les partis traditionnels ont visé les
salaires voilà or je crois que en fait
on prend la situation du mauvais côté
c'est à dire que ce n'est pas la raison
n'est pas la cause emmanuel macron mais
un symptôme emmanuel macron est arrivé à
ce moment précis de notre histoire
politique partisane démocratique ou et
effectivement les partis politiques
s'affaissait partis politiques ils sont
des corps intermédiaires ce ne sont pas
les seuls à s'être affaiblie finalement
quand on regarde mais c'est vrai que ça
fait c'est emmanuel à quoi on a profité
à proposer ce set en même temps
finalement qu'il avait même pas théorisé
si vous voulez ce sont plutôt les
journalistes quillan théorisé avant lui
et puis maintenant il s'en sert mais bon
après tout la vraie question thomas il
me semble que c est ce que le bipartisme
va revenir où est ce que cette
disparition de l air et du parti
socialiste est définitive et pour
l'instant nous n'avons pas vraiment la
réponse puisque pendant cinq ans nick
les républicains donc ni la droite ni la
gauche a réussi à se reconstruire et ce
n'est pas encore là on l'entend souvent
parce qu emmanuel macron a composé un
gouvernement avec des politiques de
gauche et de droite nicolas sarkozy l'a
fait avant lui en 2007 donc c'est
vraiment pas nouveau donc si vous voulez
à toujours regarder la poutre c'est ça
le petit proverbe à on ne voit pas la
paille dans l'oeil du voisin ne voit pas
la poutre conte à d'anciens ou donc
c'est le contraire bref on aime on est
les jeux je pense que vraiment on a une
vision qui est fou c'est 2 du maquereau
nisme alors c'est intéressant parce que
ça m'offre un lien pour votre choix
navarro pedro ouvrir un chapitre
consacré à la gauche et à jean luc
mélenchon vous avez choisi ce jour où
ségolène royal annonce qu'elle soutient
le fondateur de la france insoumis de
regarder aujourd'hui la question sera
quel sera le vote utile à gauche et
aujourd'hui c'est évident que le vote
utile à gauche passer le vote mélenchon
puisque c'est lui qui est
professionnellement qui fait la
meilleure campagne qui est entrain
d'arrondir les angles par rapport à ce
qu'ils pouvaient déplaire chez lui qui
est capable de répondre à l'ensemble des
questions qui est structuré qui est
cultivé qui a l'expérience d'une
campagne présidentielle qui sait prendre
des coups et donc c'est lui le plus
solide est ce que vous vous direz quel à
l'ancienne candidate socialiste quand
même c'est pas n'importe qui qui marlins
évidemment elle a donné un petit peu le
là on est le 16 février donc c'est ya
plusieurs semaines le signal de ce vote
utile à gauche où ce vote efficace pour
reprendre les termes de la france
insoumise et elle dit elle a dit elle
même se conquiert aujourd'hui a dit elle
même non je n'ai pas j'ai pas changé je
n'ai eu aucune influence dans la
remontée de mélenchon ce qui veut dire
oui je sais moi qui suit et
puis elle en a ajouté une couche en
disant le vote utile le pont pour
mélenchon votre futiles pour un hidalgo
la candidate du parti socialiste
évidemment il ya certains règlements de
comptes du ps d'ailleurs je vous dit
content correspondants étrangers je
pense que nous en sommes certes certain
que si nous sommes là depuis un certain
temps et en vente put suivre le parti
socialiste une des joies de notre métier
c'étaient les petites méchancetés parti
socialiste entre les défendez par des
socialistes
rarement égalé on le reste l'europe elle
était vraiment s'isoler et l'on envoie
une encore des temps anciens précisé b
de la part de ségolène royal est
évidemment dans le même temps ironie des
choses
françois hollande qui finalement se
laisse persuader de à les soutenir cette
pauvre anne hidalgo un soutien comme la
corde soutient le pendu peut-être parce
qu'il a parlé plutôt de lui et de et de
cette possibilité de prendre la tête
d'un renouveau du parti socialiste ou de
la gauche en france et donc c'est c'est
ainsi c'est assez assez en ton sur ton
pour lui parti socialiste france et je
comprends que ça ne vous surprend pas
paolo levi sur la campagne de jean luc
mélenchon c'est assez intéressant parce
que c'est sa troisième présidentielle
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment qui se
renouvelle ou alors qu'au contraire il
joue la sécurité le leader de la
française non il faut absolument la
sécurité en connais très bien jean luc
mélenchon c'est une des personnalités
les plus familières aussi pour un pour
les français aujourd'hui et donc dans sa
campagne au fond il n'y a pas eu de
grands de grandes annonces d'hier qui
qui ont marqué dix ans ces dernières
semaines par rapport au passé et il est
toujours à dents dans cette ligne un peu
floue d'ailleurs et on se demande où 6
quels sont ses réponses par rapport aux
grands enjeux
d'aujourd'hui qui sont notamment les
rapports avec la russie où il à ou s'il
a été un petit peu voilà bringuebalant
pour ne pas dire autre chose la chine
qu'est ce qu'il pense de la de l'union
européenne et de l'intégration
européenne moi ça m'a blessé à jamais ce
jour du quinquennat précédente pas
celui-là quand il était rentré à
l'assemblée nationale et en regardant le
drapeau européen à côté du drapeau
français il avait fait toute une tirade
dans dix ans enlevée moi ça c'est quoi
la vierge marie je sais pas quoi bref on
connaît ses positions disons quelque
part presque souverainiste et de repli
par rapport à cette grande aventure
qu'est qu'est la nôtre et kessel et
quelle aventure européenne donc non pas
deux je me souviens il avait été
beaucoup plus efficace qu ils ont au
moins d'un point de vue médiatique avec
le grand coup de balai on se souvient
tous dans la campagne de
2010 16 voix largage isme et le dégager
et il avait repris exactement les mêmes
éléments de langage de bègles nord le
leader du mouvement 5 et todd est donc
pour moi en tant qu'italien qui vit
entre les deux pays s'étaient trop
amusant de voir qui faisait des copies
kcal et quasiment avec le discours
degrés l'eau en italien le retrouver
pareil en france dans la bouche de jean
luc mélenchon pousse un peu plus loin
sur l'échiquier à gauche où on arrive
chez les trotskistes et richard vers
lille je me demande ce que ce qu'un
suisse pense d'une campagne française
pour la énième fois il ya deux candidats
trotskistes quand même ça doit paraître
incongrue au suisse et pouteau et
nathalie arthaud voilà pour les nommer
au moment où alain krivine est décédé
récemment
c'était une figure de cette extrême
gauche eh bien ça n'étonne pas ça
n'étonne pas parce que la tradition
révolutionnaire ça n'étonne pas en tout
cas les suisses francophones pour la
partie alémanique du pays bien
évidemment ça leur semble beaucoup plus
bizarre que deux candidats à la
présidentielle française se réclament du
mouvement trotskiste mais pour les
francophones qu'ils connaissent bien les
moeurs françaises cette tradition
révolutionnaire
elle est là ils la connaissent il voit
qu'elle est portée et puis par ailleurs
il ya quand même quelque chose
d'intéressant le fait alors il était
déjà candidat en 2017 les mêmes mais le
fait qu'ils aient eu leurs parrainages
pour poutou c'était plus serré je crois
il a il a attendu au dernier moment ça
prouve qu'il y a beaucoup de maires
j'imagine plutôt de gauche qui au fond
se font pardonner peut-être moins c'est
l'impression que ça me donne se fait
pardonner le fait que dans leur gestion
quotidienne ces maires de gauche ne sont
pas tant à gauche que ça ils gouvernent
la plupart du temps leur commune je
dirais comme les autres mais au moment
de l'élection présidentielle il ya une
sorte de caution de gauche et de gauche
jean marc procuration qu'on fait une
gauche par procuration et sage c'est
très français c'est très français il ya
un autre candidat qui pourrait profiter
de ça c'est fabien roussel d'ailleurs en
gros tous les gens de gauche en france
peut-être plutôt des classes aisées qui
auront de la peine à mettre leur
bulletin de vote pour mélenchon qui
auront en gros n'accepterons pas la
théorie du vote utile de ségolène royal
et qui sont très déçus par anne hidalgo
verts qui pensez-vous qu'il pourrait se
tourner et bien vers le candidat des
jours heureux fabien roussel donc non ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas étonnant c'est
très français de vouloir être à
l'extrême gauche à l'électeur de gauche
vont plutôt vers emmanuel macron s'il
faut pas oublier qu'il ya une bonne
partie
qui avaient voté au long du parti
socialiste un des fournées par jean
jaurès qui a toujours promu un
international
internationalisation de la politique du
parti socialiste et mélenchon et nous
fait nous vend aujourd'hui une gauche
nationaliste donc là il y a vraiment un
gouffre entre ces deux pôles allez on
arrive on avance parce que le temps le
temps file un autre moment fort de cette
campagne heures vous êtes deux à l'avoir
choisie sans vous concerter richard
werly et à l'âme seage c'est ce moment
de la campagne de marine le pen elle est
en meeting à reims on né le 5 février
elle joue la carte personnelle regard
des réalités connu la violence politique
quand j'étais petite fille à l'école on
m'a fait payer l'engagement de mon père
des persécutions
que l'esprit d'une enfant insouciante ne
peut pas vraiment comprendre
les persécutions qui me font honnir
aujourd'hui toute idée de discrimination
j'en mesure la justice j'en connais
alors je m'apprêtais à donner la parole
à des messages mais je crois qu'on a un
tout petit souci technique oui son image
là que j'ai là elle est totalement figée
donc on n'a pas la liaison mais vous
avez choisi cet extrait aussi pourquoi
bien joué bien joué son rôle parce que
c'est vrai ce qu elle dissèque la marine
le pen pour reprendre le slogan je crois
de jean lassalle elle est authentique et
elle donne l'impression d'être
authentique t elle elle parle aux à ses
sympathisants
lorsqu'elle est à reims elle le raconte
sa vie et elle retrouve ce lien cette
empathie qu'elle a souvent moi je laisse
souvent suivi marine le pen et elle est
bonne quand elle parle avec les gens
elle sait écouter les gens et là bien
elle leur parle d'elle même mais elle
leur parle dans un vocabulaire qu'ils
peuvent comprendre et elle associe
douleur et politique et ça c'est quelque
chose de très nouveau chez elle
d'habitude c'était une candidate qui
inflige la douleur aux autres notamment
aux immigrés avec son dico discours très
xénophobe et là il dit moi aussi j'ai
subi la douleur de la politique je
trouve que le vieux le revirement est
intéressant et un une des leçons par
mois un des enseignements de cette
campagne c'est que marine le pen
peut-être aiguillonné par
eghezée move on peut le penser elle a
retrouvé un créneau lc
présidentialiser d'une certaine manière
ou en tout cas elle a retrouvé une
manière de parler aux gens qui est
audible et qui ne se limite pas ses
thèmes xénophobe et anti-immigré way
pour la petite histoire
cette cet entre commandes et sur ce
surgissement de l'intimité de marine le
pen vient en fait de son expérience chez
karine le marchand sur m6 jean sur m6 où
elle avait fait cette émission eric
zemmour n'a rien à voir là dedans tenons
pas qu'en fait elle avait fait cette
émission
où elle racontait un peu sa vie tout
c'est sa famille et ses terres et ses
confessions intimes et ça fait vraiment
fonctionné dans son équipe on s'était
dit tiens c'est une facette de marine le
pen qui me voilà dans l'instant est un
peu inconnu du public et c'est vraiment
de point de vue de la communication
politique très efficace et donc ils sont
travaillés avec marine le pen pour
réussir à avoir la même efficacité que
sur le divan de karine le marchand sur
la scène vérité c'est pas c'est pas salé
c'est intéressant on a retrouvé à l'âme
said eux qui étaient avec nous la
liaison est rétabli et c'est très bien
on vient de voir allam l'extrait que
vous aviez choisi marine le pen à reims
donc cette cette carte intimiste qu'est
ce qui vous a frappé dans ce moment de
la campagne de de la candidate du
rassemblement national
que ça a marché j'étais dans la salle
à l'époque c'était pas évident de venir
devant devant de la scène parler comme
ça de soi même je trouve que ça a
fonctionné à contrairement à valérie
pécresse qui a essayé de faire un peu la
même chose a
donc je pense que ça c'était est
alors malheureusement la vie qui seront
ça risque de barder des pépins
techniques on va peut-être continuer
vous aurez terminaison téléphonique ça
on est sûr que sa
sauce au 20e siècle mais c'est pas grave
on va être sûr que ça m'a parlé comme si
je parlais de valérie pécresse et de son
big thing votre choix paulo lévis et
c'est justement ce meeting au zénith une
valérie pécresse une candidate lr pas
forcément à l'aise dans l'exercice on va
dire ça comme ça on regarde
moi président de la république aucune
femme ne sera soumise je crois à la
liberté je combats l'emprise je prie
viens je n'accepterai jamais de
soumettre la république marianne n'est
pas une femme voilée
voilà il faut il faut laisser la
séquence effectivement durer un petit
peu parce que les silences et et
créateur de malaise dans ce meeting est
peut-être aussi parce que quand on était
devant sa télé on ne comprenait pas que
il y avait des applaudissements et donc
on se demandait un peu ce qu'attendaient
les graisses comment vous l'analysez
avec un peu plus de recul le levi's r
écoutez c'est ça a été
un début de campagne ratée pour les riz
pécresse
c'est dommage parce qu'elle avait
suscité cette candidature certaine
curiosité une certaine fraîcheur aussi
un peu d'espoir parce que cela au fond
aurait été une très belle un bonne
nouvelle d'avoir une éventuelle d'un
éventuel deuxième tour entre le sait pas
par exemple un emmanuel macron qui
aurait été peut-être obligé de
s'orienter plus à gauche de l'électorat
quand même une une représentante d'un
parti absolument républicains comme son
nom l'indiqué sud de la lutte au
fascisme et au nazisme en europe on doit
donc
ça a été un peu dommage parce que elle
est allée elle est partie quelque part à
la chasse de l'extrême droite et mise à
part disons la mimique qui voit là n'est
pas exactement le maximum du naturel
contrairement
effectivement il faut lui rendre c'est
tout à son honneur elle a souvent été
très naturel et c'est peut-être un de
ses atouts et messi aussi pardon d
interrompre c'est le fruit de plusieurs
campagnes présidentielles faut jamais
oublier que deux analyses que jean luc
mélenchon elle en est à sa troisième
rentrée spontanée marine le pen sur ça
il n'y a rien à dire
c'est complètement voilà complètement
raté son débat c'est exactement de lento
donne est bien sûr le même syndrome de
valérie pécresse voyez avec une
prestation télévisée parce que là le
meeting de valérie pécresse était
télévisée donc vous voyez le poids de
l'image c'est à dire que vous ratez vous
imaginez vous ratez une émission et
c'est fini puisque carrière thomas c'est
fou en fait j'en ai raté beaucoup
couperet de l'opinion publique qu'il
tombe et c'est injuste
si vraiment on prend un peu de recul
c'est uniquement une prestation c'est
uniquement une présence scénique mais
donc ça se travaille les
autocollants pour finir je pense qu'elle
a trahi quelque part les valeurs mêmes
mains des républicains quand elle a cité
la fée ce passage sur le grand
remplacement qui franchement était
déplacé une candidate public avec une
phrase qui était très ambigu même si
elle est revenue le lendemain mais
morrow au delà de la forme je trouve que
c'est intéressant je vais vous entendre
là dessus eux alain allard ou pedro sur
effectivement c est ce que ce meeting
n'était pas rater parce que le choix
stratégique de courir après eric ciotti
est derrière lui eric zemmour ne
correspondait pas fondamentalement à
l'histoire politique de de valérie
pécresse c'est le gros problème n a pas
été elle même marine le pen elle séduit
à nouveau elle s'est complètement raté
en 2017 elle s'est relevée
reconnu et leurs partis au combat les
français aiment ça et les électeurs
français aiment bien ça quelqu'un qui a
de jacques chirac qui avait pris
et les mêmes effets mix et notre
campagne on voit qu'elle remonte elle
est elle-même la fir ce sens sur
sympathie pour tout une petite
parenthèse sa glisser sur elle comme de
l'eau sur les sur l'île sur un canard
quoi ce n'est pas le cas des autres
candidats pour valérie pécresse s'était
tout le problème n'était pas elle-même
elle elle s'est laissée convaincre par
les experts en communication par
l'entourage du parti je ne sais pas par
qui mais elle savait c'est de convaincre
des firmes contrat de calais et quand on
veut être président il faut savoir dire
non alors je redonne la parole adam said
par téléphone cette fois ci sur valérie
pécresse vous écoutent
oui je pense si vous m'entendez
maintenant je crois que le problème
valérie pécresse et qu' elle même si
elle est elle-même effectivement un
point est le premier musée magnin à cran
et tout ce problème tout péter bills
accompagne ses effets de chercher à
démontrer
une différence avec allemagne mâcon qui
n'est pas véritablement à réel ou qui
est très très petit ce qui l'amène à
jouer cette suite c'est drôle que tu
manques comme comme
les autres personnes et que qui n'est
pas
authentique qui n'est pas sincère et que
je pense que
nos élites en découlent de ça
alors à un dernier temps fort c'est bien
il nous reste le temps de le le le
l'analyse et en profondeur
on va revenir sur la campagne d'eric
zemmour maintenant c'est le choix que
vous avez fait richard wehrli vous
n'étiez pas le seul à et beaucoup de
deux propositions autour d'eric zemmour
on né le 6 mars dernier c'est le
ralliement alors il y avait eu il avait
été un peu étonné ce ralliement ils
demandent marion maréchal meeting commun
à tous l'ont regardé
car je suis absolument convaincu qu'eric
zemmour est le mieux placé dans cette
élection présidentielle
voilà une question aux sondages c'est
une question de perspective politique
la politique c'est une dynamique c'est
une relation de confiance qui se 6 avec
les français ce sont des passerelles qui
se construisent c'est une compétence qui
ça fait rien c'est un souffle en un
temps record vous avez déjà commencé
avec les ai beaucoup de pourquoi je
plaide depuis desana idée construire
cette grande union à droite tu aimais
réussi à faire vivre chaque jour en
attirant dans son sillage des
personnalités issues de l air tu es
rennais d'ailleurs changé avez fait vous
l'avez refaire
richard vers l'iss qui est intéressant
c'est qu'on est le 6 mars à ce moment là
eric zemmour et est déjà dans une phase
descendante en tout cas dans les
sondages on reste prudent comme toujours
dans cette émission donc elles ne volent
pas au secours de la victoire
ce à ce moment là elle joue le coup
d'après c'est ce qu'elle dit d'ailleurs
dans cet extrait qu'on a choisi oui
alors tout à l'heure quand on parlait de
marine le pen je disais bien joué là on
pourrait dire rater c'est à ces ratés
non seulement sur le calendrier le
moment où elle s'exprime mais c'est
aussi raté dans la forme vous avez vu
elle lit sont est elle lit son texte
elle donne vraiment l'impression d'avoir
une partition est ce qu'elle est ce que
c'est sa partition la partition de
quelqu'un d'autre et au fond on a avant
tout l'impression qu'elle règle des
comptes avec sa tante et avec sa
formation d'origine qui est
rassemblement national bref c'est tout
ce qu'il ne faut pas faire pour
justement donner une dynamique elle
utilise le mot dynamique mais à ce
moment là on comprend qu'il n'y en a pas
mais là vous êtes sur la forme sur le
fond il ya quand même cette stratégie
d'union dès droite je ne dis pas que
c'est écrit et que ça va forcément
marcher mais c'est elle est cohérente
avec ce qu'elle défend depuis depuis un
salon observe la politique français je
pense qu'elle est cohérente le terme
union de la droite il est cohérent quand
c'est eric zemmour qu'il prononce il ne
l'est pas quand c'est marion maréchal
parce que marion maréchal elle a
toujours été vraiment à l'époque où il
était au rassemblement national elle
était quand même perçu comme une minute
j'ai la frange dure du et rennes alors
qu'est ce qui les rassemble tous les
deux je finis par croire que c'est
peut-être le simple fait qu'il
représente tous les deux cette droite
mais il mise beaucoup sur cette droite
méridionale la droite du sud de la
france et ricciotti n'est pas loin non
plus là il y a une famille politique
bien identifiés mais une autre chose
c'est que mal au maréchal contrairement
à sa tante elle ne parle pas aux
électeurs populaires du tout et les
arguments qu'elle emploie les électeurs
populaires c'est pas du tout leurs trucs
dont moi je pense que pour l jeunes
politiques sauf à miser une implantation
dans le sud mais elle avait déjà avant
je ne vois pas ce que ça constitue comme
tremplin tant pour elle que pour eric
zemmour est d'ailleurs le l'électorat
d'eric zemmour on l'a plusieurs fois
analysé ici il n'est pas vraiment
populaire il est plutôt classe moyenne
plutôt
bourgeois et est âgée parler lévis vous
aviez assisté alors pas à se mettre la
main au meeting d'eric zemmour à
villepinte là on est le 5 décembre donc
on est dans la première phase de sa
campagne ou au contraire il est plutôt
dans une la portée par la thématique sa
thématique sa monothématique j'allais
dire de l'immigration et de l'islam
qu'est-ce qui vous avez frappé quels
souvenirs vous en gardez de ce meeting
la violence
10 ans ça a été une journée assez
particulière dans le sens on s'attendait
vraiment ça devait être le tremplin pour
mais
pour cette campagne d'eric zemmour est
très vite ça s'est transformé en une
sorte de film de western avec des
chaises qui volaient d'un côté à l'autre
de la salle donc ma réflexion
personnelle n'a été si ce monsieur veut
garantir ne peut garantir
là n'est pas vraiment pas en mesure de
garantir la sécurité de ce meeting j'ose
pas imaginer qu'est ce qu'il va faire
pour garantir l à la sécurité d'un pays
entier après moi j'avais ou aussi
beaucoup de questionnements par rapport
à des réponses parce que lui il
évoque tout le temps cette question
identitaire qui est vraiment son son
mantra mais quant aux autres grandes
questions qu'est ce qui nous dit de la
chine deux des grands enjeux d'avenir il
en parle très peu moi pour la petite
histoire j'ai eue avec lui un débat
assez surréel pendant la pandémie je
vous le raconte parce que très
rapidement se taire c'est drôle parce
qu'on était en direct sur une petite
chaîne premier de la télévision
française et un certain moment moi je
cherchais de défendre un petit peu
l'idée européenne le fait qu'on devait
être tous ensemble main dans la main
pour répondre à la pandémie et et lui il
m'a répondu cher monsieur l'italie
n'existe pas l'italie devrait être
française et vous les italiens vous
devrez être français parce que si
napoléon avait gagné vous aurez français
sans que moi je me demande en adoration
pendaison finale parce qu'ils sont
restés bloqués au monde rang des mots
continue risque qu'un tel homme peut
représenter s'il accédait à l'elysée
aujourd'hui ça serait vraiment un
désastre le vrai suicide français pour
citer son livre leur élection de zemmour
je me retourne de nouveau vers l'âme
celte parce que vous vouliez vous aussi
intervenir sur un autre moment de la
campagne d'eric zemmour heureusement
qu'on n'a pas choisi tout vos extraits
sinon on aurait fait toutes les missions
sur des mots bref là on est le 19
janvier à calais je crois que vous allez
sentiment que sa compagne elle bascule
un petit peu ce jour là c'est ça le
passé sa compagne a basculé ce jour là
en tout cas à
géant parce que ce jour là tout son
manque d'expérience et najjari d'ériger
quoi que ce soit dans sa vie il n'est
même pas servi ce journal et son manque
d'expérience était assez évident il
était sur une colline qui surplombe de
l'ancien gendre à akalé maintenant vides
à aider c'est de tenir un disco et
environs vont pas possible qui a haché
tous ses volets de son discours à qui
nous empêchait de dons quoique ce soit
qu'un journée très spéciale où il jouait
à achat et a souri avec une manifestante
rappelle
son équipe annoncée aux journées sont
internés moment où il allait être
trouvé autour du pot a finalement à la
fin de cette journée à six spéciales les
manifestants d'un détestons a
essentiellement des activistes des
volontaires qui travaillent avec
migrants à calais un propos et sociales
n'ont retrouvé doit situer dans un
bistrot à marcq ce qui veut dire que
tout est calé à l'ancienne manifestation
à dos alors que l'huile et yan thériault
en train de parler aux policiers bon ça
si ça finit cas ce qu il a fallu qu'on
extirpe en porte arrière a
pendant que son équipe de campagne
refuse une conférence de presse devant
le préfet de distraire tout le monde et
je me suis dit ce jour là il n'a pas
l'expérience
il n'a pas l'équipe ne peut pas
rivaliser
merci
sur le fait d'avoir plusieurs campagnes
derrière soi on a commencé ce débat par
une question de communication et
télévisions va le terminer sur ce même
thème avec la question d'un débat avant
le premier tour et je vous propose
d'écouter ce que disait il ya quelques
jours 17 mars yannick jadot sur un
emmanuel macron qui refusent de débattre
une responsabilité évidente il est si
fébrile sur son bilan qui veut pas en
débattre et donc évidemment l'inaction
climatique a été sanctionné même par la
justice française et on voit les
régressions sociales tous les jours donc
il nous faut un beau et grand débat
démocratique pour tirer toutes les
leçons de ces crises pour savoir comment
les uns et les autres veulent y réponde
et que ce soit un vrai choix positif de
société pour les cinq prochaines années
parce que si on n'arrive pas à purger
par la politique les tensions de la
société et bien effectivement notre
démocratie est en danger
66% des français souhaitent un débat
avant le premier tour alain navarro
pedro pourquoi emmanuel macron irait
servir de punching ball aux autres onze
autres candidats le temple avant goût
au parlement européen oui quand il s'y
est présenté et que les élus français du
parlement européen lui sont tombés à
bras raccourcis clavier c'est mal perçu
d'ailleurs par les autres députés
européens si je ne suis pas tous ouais à
tous parce que voyez emmanuel macron est
apprécié à la fois un tout petit peu
parfois fait grincer des dents en europe
dans d'autres chancelleries
son cv son attitude avec les français un
petit peu hautaine un petit peu t plus
rude parfois il a qu'avec les autres si
agacé aussi plongé dans sa langue
ben voilà on terminera là dessus merci
beaucoup c'était passionnant vous
écoutez nous entendre les uns et les
autres voilà revit finalement quelques
moments forts de cette campagne
présidentielle et on continuera de la
faire vivre et évidemment sur notre
antenne et dans cette émission en
faisant des gros plans sur les les
programmes des candidats tient demain on
vous proposera un débat autour de du rsa
et de la proposition du candidat macron
richard werly votre livre c'est la
france contre elle même il sort
aujourd'hui il est publié chez grasset